hier dans l'émotion n'est revenue sur le
coup de gueule de jean marie bigard sur
flosbach france bleu suite à la crise
actuelle
des propos qui ont fait réagir notre
invité gérard jugnot qui était présent
sur le plateau et jean marie bigard a
tenu à lui répondre
donc voilà donc là on est à vous allez
voir vous allez voir il y aurait de
booba qui est un petit hommage à
jean-marie regarde l on annonce tout
simplement qu'ils étaient pmp gérard
jugnot donc vous parler de deux mois
cyril hanouna en tête dit on connaît
bien jean marie il est sincère et gérard
jugnot
sa réplique c'est hitler aussi était
sincère et c'est très fort le matin vers
8h le matin tu te prends une comparaison
avec le plus gros monstre 2 de
l'humanité bobin gérard je vais dire
j'ai un petit mot d'excusés tu dis j'ai
voulu faire une blague mais je me suis
viande et ça ça arrive aux plus grands
et je ne veux pas alors c'est moi je
suis très embêté parce que j'adore les
deux vous savez ton mari c'est vraiment
quelqu'un que j'aime énormément et qui
est un amour de mec est comme gelée
d'hier elle est vraiment sincère dans
ses propos c'est un mytho jean marie
gérard jugnot j'aime beaucoup également
et c'est vrai que ça me fait de la peine
voilà que ce soit vous avez vos petites
pancartes
vous avez voilà ce que vous comprenez la
colère de jean marie bigard contre
gérard jugnot nicolas et non parce qu'on
nous d'abord on a vu gérard jugnot
quand il a dit ça il a dit effectivement
c'est une mauvaise blague ou c'est une
connerie d'accord on était sur le
plateau tous ensemble après de l'autre
côté c'est vrai que quand on a regardé
les images de jean marie bigard face à
je crois dorothée c'était assez
effrayant quoi il lui aurait hurlé il y
aurait comme ça à la très énervé puis le
fourgon comprenait pas ce qu'il essayait
de passer comme message
donc c'est vrai que juno il a voulu
apaiser un peu le truc et détendre
l'atmosphère mais à aucun moment c'est
une connerie j'aime ses déboires
l'internet mais repart donc tout le
monde l'appelle dorothée dans
l'habitacle
attendons de le dire mais on peut ne pas
être d'accord avec la main avec
jean-marie effectivement c'était un
propos un peu pas là qui lui qui lui
ressemble mais là c'est vrai que la
comparaison je peux comprendre ce que
comparé malheureux mais c'est très
malheureux mais j'aimerais genou il n'a
pas fait ça mais c'était un bon mot mais
je comprends que en plus c'est un grand
sensible en art il faut le savoir il est
vraiment sensible et je comprends que ça
des penne voilà maintenant c'est ce
qu'il a dit jean marie l'a dit moi j'ai
trouvé ces réactions la réaction de jean
marie bigard extrêmement noble élégante
quand même il est vachement sympa parce
que ça peut être très vexant effectué à
aurélie clair c'est une mauvaise vanne
glisser comme ça en direct on dit
souvent des bêtises en direct je suis
sûr que je gérard que j'ai avec ce genre
de truc aussi moi j'adore jean-marie
alors je redis j'ai relevé aussi que les
invités sur les plateaux de télé
maintenant ils vont plus rien dire oui
on peut réagir barrières bien sûr mais
oui c'est ce qui va se faire peur de
réagir à un tel sujet à tel autre studio
a plaisir à se dire non je peux pas
gérard il venait gentiment ici il a
voulu faire un bon mot il a réagi à tous
il a pas au chili à réagir à tout ce
qu'on lui a demandé gêne et toute
l'actualité et c'est vrai que derrière
les gens vont dire alors non maintenant
moi je viens dans touche pas à mon pote
je fais juste ma promo mais je veux
réagir à rien et ça ce serait vraiment
regrettable alors les séries et je vais
vous dire un truc comme ultra important
média + émission en direct aujourd'hui
ouais c'est vrai que ça fait partie des
rares émissions en direct à bayonne les
artistes ne veulent pas venir avec
démission en direct à cause de ça donc
s'il vous plaît quand un mec on peut
faire des erreurs on sait faire des
conneries en quoi est-ce que jugnot est
un nazi nous on ne l'a fait sa connerie
s'est planté il ces cinq jours d'un
changement
et attention à ça parce que la télé elle
va devenir un s'examiner sinon ça va
devenir pour la raison nicolas ça va
devenir plus insupportable on aura plus
d'un mythique qui voudra venir en direct
réagir sur les sujets de société
moi je vous le dis je le dis aux
téléspectateurs comme une fois qu'elle
est invitée que ouvert mercredi à la
programmatrice
je viens mais je fais juste la promo que
s'ils ne parlent pas tel ou tel sujet je
veux pas parler de tel truc qui s'est
passé de manwin de sécurité des trucs je
veux pas rentrer là dedans je veux pas
d'histoires
derrière et c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué oui je pense que gérard jugnot
était un peu choqué aussi par le message
de jean-marie bigard parce qu'on n'en a
pas parlé hier
mais jean-marie milliards quand même là
il est en train de dire que le coc vie
c'est un complot c'est ce qu'il dit dans
l'extrait de de france bleu que tout ça
est un crime organisé par une espèce
même pas par l'état par espèce de
puissance au dessus de l'état par une
organisation secrète
donc je comprends que ça puisse agacer
dans qu'il entend de certains propos
après la été maladroit il faut pas
comparer les gens est clair c'est pas
bien mais le message de jean-marie
bigard c'était déjà choquant sur la
forme parce qu'il a hurlé il a fumé un
peu à la gueule de l'animatrice et
pardon mais sur le fond c'est choquant
de dire que le coc vide c'est un complot
contre nous fin ça m'apporte pardon oui
nous trouve un peu hypocrite parce que
hier on s'insurge contre jean-marie
bigard qui gueule et toi tu dis nicolas
aujourd'hui non mais c'est très bien
parce qu'ils demandent c'est qu'on
trouve que hier si je trouve qu'on l'a
un peu balayé quand même d'un revers de
manche en particulier gérard jugnot
je pense qu'il est malgré tout le reflet
d'une exaspération d'une colère d'un
burnout psychologique de plein de gens
on n'est pas égaux tous face à ceux à
face à ce virus et anna qui explose et
qui n'en peuvent plus il lui fait partie
aussi de ça il sait aussi ça fait partie
aussi des gens de la société
ouais je trouve que pour faire l'avocat
du diable qui ne compare pas une claire
c'est à dire qu'il dit l'un n'empêche
pas l'autre on peut être sincère et fou
la preuve avec une arme et il ne pointe
pas du doigt après voilà prêt après
girard et la dizaine et on en dirait que
je vous dire le jour et est le vrai
danger c'est ce que disent et nicolas et
c'est ce qu'on dit des c'est qu'on est
plus d'invités qui veuille réagir à
l'actualité on a besoin d'avoir des
invités qui réagissent à l'actu
qui réagissent à ohio may notre monde
d'aujourd'hui oui il ya plein de blagues
qu'on fait dans la vraie vie tout le
monde trouve ça drôle tout le monde
rigole quand on est fait sur un plateau
télé ça choque tout le monde
et c'est le même discours et en plus on
est toujours en train de se plaindre des
gens qui nous critiquent sur internet et
qu'on pût pure est intéressé mais si les
artistes entre eux commencent à se tirer
dans les pattes et à faire des trucs de
télé a été quand j'ai envie d'écouter
manama je suis pas d'accord parce que
mine de rien c'est le girard et on l'a
fait c'est nous qui l'aurons alors dans
ce cas là on peut dire c'est nous qui
avons mis de l'huile sur le feu ce en
faisant réagir
j'alerte à la vidéo mais ça veut dire
que tout va se déchaîner tu mon avion va
s'insulter civile mais ça faisait ça
tout ça naze bah non moi je trouve ça
mine de rien le dialogue c'est important
non mais en face et on se voit sur un
plateau quand on dit rien moi je fermais
les yeux 50 secondes je me suis pour
rien j'ai pas ouvert la nouvelle wii et
isabelle mon niveau ce qui est accusé de
dormir ça 22h04
franchement ça c'est pas sympa pour l
est